man wird ja auch jetzt immer wieder
hören von der langsamen durchseuchung
der gesellschaft das heißt dass eine
immunität besteht jetzt habe ich in den
zeitungen auch in den medien gelesen
dass in südkorea gab es 91 bestätigte
fälle von menschen die im februar
bereits krone hatten die dann wieder
positiv getestet worden also die sich
wieder infiziert haben oder
beziehungsweise das virus wieder aktiv
wurde weiß man dann wie sicher weiß man
dass man immun ist also herr stürmer
sie hatten ja das virus bereits und wir
haben noch letzte woche darüber
gesprochen acht sie haben ja jetzt
eigentlich entspannt also ihnen geht es
gut weil sie nicht mehr aufpassen müssen
ist das jetzt doch anders oder hat sie
das erstaunt ja ich habe die berichte
auch gelesen und teile die meinung
vieler vieler antrag kollegen auch dass
man erst mal einer nachmachen muss sonst
eigentlich test passiert und was schief
gelaufen ist weil es ist doch
interessant also das phänomen jetzt hier
so gewalt als zeichen südkorea aber
ansonsten keine berichte aus anderen
betroffenen ländern hören du hast das
immer mehr weil ich glaube dass ein
allgemein verbreitetes phänomen wäre das
virus ist reaktivieren können sprecher
sich es in unserem körper
unser immunsystem hat es angefangen das
zu definieren
hier sind negative testen und dann kommt
das virus sowie doch noch mal was
passiert also das phänomen was in korea
beschreiben wenn man das - vermehrt
gehabt hätten würden wenn wir nicht
solche solche dynamik mini zahlen sind
sondern sie würden ganz ganz viel mehr
für alle schüler haben sind insofern
glaube ich nicht dass das ein
allgemeines phänomen ist man muss das
genau untersuchen was da passiert ist
ist und da muss man ein bisschen zeit
nehmen
also hoffen wir einfach dass es eine
viel testung war eine fehlinformation
oder was auch immer dass man von einer
immunität nach einer infektion ausgehen
kann